[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley part of The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network his weekly show a unique
Journey around the sports entertainment
cultural landscape it's called more to
it with Marcellus Wiley wherever you
listen to your podcast Tom Brady's
announcement your reaction was what two
hours ago
ah my reaction the first one no lie was
Deja Vu like we've been here before
um obviously it's an emotional time for
anybody who plays the game of football
especially at the level of greatness of
Tom Brady uh you still see two teams
fighting for what we all fought for
which is that championship and Tom Brady
obviously the winner of seven of those
is thinking in this moment he fills a
void he feels the absence but I think
this one is real
um one because he's just been through so
much it's like how much more toothpaste
can you squeeze out the tube so I really
believe that he's being authentic in
this moment that said it really made me
reflect because I was on the field and I
was literally four inches away it felt
like Dan from sacking Tom Brady when he
threw his first career passing touchdown
against my San Diego Chargers I saw the
video like a year ago someone sent it to
me I come around the corner and I'm
coming up coming he launches the ball
his first touchdown ever and it made me
reflect because I'm a starter in the
league like I replaced Bruce Smith
before Tom Brady got on the field then
we had a career simultaneously then I
retired from football became a media
personality and pivoted out of like
traditional media and then sitting here
with you Dan right now and he still was
playing football like it's just unreal
to see that level of greatness but is it
tougher to get to the point to announce
your retirement or actual retirement
oh great question I think the toughest
part is getting to that place like
coming up with all of the pros and cons
because that's what's so tiring I
remember I went through this process
much lower level but I was playing with
the Dallas Cowboys that was the first
time it entered my head like I'm coming
down the hill and I think I might want
to accelerate this I think it's over and
I was talking to Darren Woodson my my
teammate at the time who said once you
start thinking about retirement you're
basically retired and it's a process
because you're weighing the good with
the bad with the reality that once you
say it's over it is truly over you die a
football death you've been doing it
since you were eight years old it's the
best job in the world it's a man's and
childhood dream coming together and
you're sitting there like I'm about to
say no to this like they're not forcing
you out you actually gonna raise your
hand and say I'll tap out the toughest
thing is getting to that place where you
raise your hand and you were 33 three
yeah young man and had to Dan I got
dropped into the real world didn't know
which way was up thankfully I found
media but I really reflect on moments
like that because you just don't know
what to do my whole life was an
itinerary and all of a sudden I'm out
here with all these choices had five
dollars in my pocket and didn't know
which way was up but I finally found my
way talking to Marcellus Wiley the
former NFL All-Pro defensive and you
know that life after football and trying
to and and I mentioned this if Tom Brady
is going to find an attachment to
football going out to the games is so
much more important I think for him than
being in the studio
because oh absolutely you that's as
close as you get he can go out and
actually prepare for both opponents
and you know that's why I thought Drew
Brees missed out he was in you know in a
sterile environment in the studio you
just retired and then you try to go out
and call games and it didn't work out
but when you're in that moment like Tony
Romo when you get in that moment like
you're excited you're you know it's as
close as you get to playing but you know
Terry and Halle and those guys are in
the studio and it's you know probably
tough to get that you know energy that
momentum uh that fire that fight in you
yeah I had this uh discussion I won't
call it an argument with Mike Tarico one
day we're at the airport just talking
for a few minutes and um
he loves going to the games because of
the energy because of exactly what you
said the thrill of like preparing for
both sides and this is a guy who didn't
play right so for Tom Brady you can see
the pros of that but let me give you the
flip side of that coin because my my
thoughts were I love the studio why
because I can go to the studio I have
structure I have my set times I'm in I'm
out that's it it's simple I'm still a
part of the game I still get to express
my passion but I'm not traveling the
entire country the entire world like
I've been doing for the last 20 years so
some guys just want to ease up on the
travel and those demands and to still be
a part of the game so we were just
talking about pros and cons one of the
cons of actually calling games is you
have to go where the games are and
sometimes when you're retired just want
to sit back and relax all right uh the
demiko Ryan's higher in Houston and you
had Sean Payton in Denver
which one uh excites you the most
oh Sean Payton in Denver uh because of
the apprehension in this one like if you
heard the reports there were conflicting
reports about how the meeting went in
Denver how he got along with ownership
in Denver and then demiko Ryan's was a
candidate but he wasn't in Denver and to
me that just reeks of apprehension and I
tell you why I think it's Sean Payton
looking at Russell Wilson and looking at
this dynamic because it was a ready-made
Super Bowl roster before Russell all
they needed was a competent quarterback
and they thought they got a competent
quarterback but they didn't get that
last year out of Russell Wilson so if
you're Sean Payton who everyone loves
he's the best thing going do you want to
go to a situation where when you do a
proper evaluation Russell Wilson is in
who Russell Wilson's supposed to be
Russell Wilson has been whispered about
for many years in Seattle hey he's not
the leader y'all think he is hey he's
not the offensive Firepower weapon you
think he is he doesn't go hold the ball
like you think he does not on schedule
not reliable and everyone was saying
that and we used to slight them because
we were like oh you're just mad cause
Russell's so successful but now you look
back running game top in the league
defense top in the league when he had
his most success when they said here the
keys the car kind of went off the track
went off the road
okay as do you think in the words being
used is fix can Sean Payton fix Russell
Wilson
no can't fix Russell Wilson what you got
to do is dress Russell Wilson up you got
to give him the proper assets resources
they have players what you have to do is
give them the scheme you got to give
them the system that he wants to play in
being real evaluating Russell Wilson he
licks his chops when the plays break
down now last year he didn't have
success when the plays were breaking
down but typically Russell Wilson will
look at a plate call that play and hope
that play doesn't work so Russell Wilson
can now be Russell Wilson like he
activates when the play breaks down in
structure that's a problem that's not
reliable that's not predictable or
offensive coordinator is pulling his
hair out like dude I called this flat
patter and here you go scrambling around
yeah you completed the post but how
often can we call the flat that turns
into the post we have to stick to the
script and I think that's the most
difficult thing about Russell he doesn't
stick to the script that's impossible to
fix gotta just dress it up he did stick
to this script on this date in 2015 when
Malcolm Butler had the interception ah
don't do that man you imagine being on
that team Dan I mean no one ever wants
to blame one guy for it except you know
when we watch the Ohio State kicker
everyone's like yo you did that but
outside of that you never want to blame
one guy for one thing but if I were a
Seahawk I'd be looking at Russell Wilson
like brother uh you and Pete Carroll who
called this why did we do that lose the
Super Bowl for one play that's that's
horrible okay take me back or at least
what your thought was Joseph A sigh
chasing Patrick Mahomes you're taught to
those guys up front you you get paid by
hitting the quarterback your job is to
hit the quarterback get to the
quarterback
how hard is it to pull up in a situation
like that
yeah great point I talked about it on
the podcast in the sense of people don't
know what maniacal is don't know what
manika looks like I played with guys who
were so laser singularly focused that
when they saw color they would hit color
no matter where the color was just
Rodney Harrison goodness I have scars on
my back still for Rodney Harrison just
coming into Power like I don't care what
happened I don't care if I heard the
whistle I'm still gonna see color and
hit color right so in that sense I was
never that guy and that's in part why I
wasn't as great as some of those guys I
always was thinking on the field I was
always calculating on the field oh he's
coming close out of bounds led up Wiley
versus Rodney was like I don't even see
out of bounds everything's blurry I just
see meat I'm about to eat so what's
difficult in that moment is some guys
are wired to just go all out go all in
and some guys are not but the guys who
are are like that make more plays than
not Joseph aside is a good player like
he makes plays sideline to sideline so
it's very difficult based on the wiring
Charles Woodson says I'm wrong we talked
about this he's like look I don't give a
damn how good how great you are you know
the game you know the rules and you know
when to hit them that said some guys
just don't they just go at it you talked
about on the podcast how LeBron James is
embracing nepotism
yeah I have to um one his son's at
Sierra Canyon his last year Sons ranked
like 40th in the country which is
amazing but he still takes criticism
because he's LeBron's son and I guess
he's not number one point being
McDonald's All-American Game he gets
invited but he's 40. and they only take
the top 24. so all of a sudden
everyone's coming at Ronnie James for
like how'd you get in the game well you
know how you got in the game dummy it's
Daddy name it's like a Peyton Eli with
an Archie attached like yeah that's
gonna help you as it should and I think
finally I'm starting to see from LeBron
James some of his remarks like he
understands what nepotism is one of the
things I hate about culture at large is
that they actually want us to accept
that we shouldn't like nepotism when as
a parent what do you think I'm working
for what do you think I'm doing this for
it's not for my son or daughter to be
born on third base it's for them to stay
on home plate don't even have to circle
the bases like dude I'm giving them the
world and let them fail forward and if
they are oh my God those are some brats
I'll take a successful brat as a child
but the point is you gotta open up as
many doors as you can I'm starting to
see that with LeBron finally
what you have said to your son don't
don't go to the game
like could you see the logic if you say
hey you know what you didn't deserve it
I I you know we got to work on your game
like I I'm just spitballing here of you
know these are all teaching moments here
and and what are you teaching what do
you want to teach in a situation like
that
yeah I would have never told them to not
go to the game because I think the
meritocracy that we're all subscribing
to especially you and I old school it's
out the window it's gone like it's
always laced with a little bit of luck a
little bit of favoritism agenda whatever
you want to call it and I want my child
to understand that that's a part of the
equation so don't ever go into a
situation I give you this story to
really bring it home I was in the
admissions Department
at Columbia when they were looking at
new emissions and new prospects and 4.0
1600 GP uh sat 4.0 1600 sat left and
right denied denied denied what were
they looking for more than just that
something more than just the objective
number so you need more to your resume
even to get into college extracurricular
activities be on a sports program Etc
same thing in life like you got to have
more than just like a ball and I think
bronnie Campbell he qualifies but more
so he brings big business to the game
which will make everyone happy and I
bring this up all the time and it drives
I think part of my fan base crazy you
know we put on TV shows you know the the
playoffs are TV show All-Star games you
know the the Heisman everything it's a
TV show and you have to look look at it
through that lens March Madness it's a
TV show oh how did that coach you know
match up against now his former team
it's a TV show that's what you're
selling to America and I it feels like
the more you embrace it the more at
least you understand what is going on
now exactly man we all care how the
medicine tastes right and sometimes
people become purists no no no all I
want is the game and that's it top 24
that's all I want to see no you don't
you want it laced with something that is
going to be easier to digest easier to
consume easier to watch no lie I am now
going to watch yeah I am too because
Ronnie James is playing yes and that's
no slight to the top 24 players I don't
even know who is the number one player
well I know who number 40 is and that's
who got my attention I'm watching Brony
uh great to talk to you we'll uh we'll
talk to you we'll see you next week
let's do it brother Marcellus Wiley
former All-Pro defensive end the host of
the podcast on The Dan Patrick Podcast
Network it's entitled more to it and
that's exactly who Marcellus is went
from Compton to Columbia